so the State of the Union address was
last night as I'm sure you're aware it
was good good speech Trump did a did a
great job with it I thought the speech
was inspirational
soaring well delivered hit the right
notes love the pro-life bit I'll talk
more about that in a minute I like the
part about the wall we'll talk more
about that as well but he made the case
for the wall very well now unfortunately
it's not gonna matter in the long term
well it won't matter really by next week
because nobody is gonna remember this
speech by like tomorrow everyone will
have forgotten and moved on not because
the speech was not memorable I thought
it was was memorable or should be
memorable except that nothing is
memorable in our culture because nobody
remembers anything for more than 24
hours we just everything moves on and
everyone forgets everything nothing
lasts nothing matters
that is my cheerful thought to begin the
day but still you you have to make the
most of the opportunities that you are
given and even if they are fleeting and
Trump definitely did a good job with the
speech as I have said many times Trump
is the scripted version of struck Trump
is vastly superior to the unscripted
version there's there's no competition
and I in it's just I can't believe that
anyone would dispute this anymore
compare something like State of the
Union address or take really any of his
scripted speeches but look take the
State of the Union compare that to how
he is on Twitter for instance or to the
kind of speech that he would give to a
rally somewhere in Pensacola Florida or
whatever compare the two and it's just
there's no question that the scripted
version is much much more compelling
more coherent just much more focused in
everything it's just it's just much
better and I know that when I say that
it seems like an insult because it seems
like it's just another way of saying
that Trump is only good when he's saying
things that other people have written
for him to say but
it's not actually insulting and by the
way that's true for probably most people
most people you're gonna sound better
with a speech written by a speech writer
then you will just off-the-cuff talking
into a microphone that's why I say I
think pretty much everyone sounds better
the other way so it's not really an
insult and there's something else to it
also that the reason why I think Trump
is compelling when he's giving scripted
speeches is that he is willing to say
things in speeches that other Republican
presidents won't say and that's what
that's why that's the really could be
the very valuable thing about Donald
Trump is that he is willing to put out a
message now he needs help crafting it
but if he gets help crafting and he's
willing to say this thing so for
instance as I mentioned he talked about
the wall and that whole chunk of the
speech was very good it was also
something that you probably wouldn't
hear from any other Republican president
we haven't heard from any other
Republican president and this is where
Trump was extremely effective when he's
delivering a message that is his message
his unique message but he's had help
putting it all together so let's take a
look at him here he is making the case
for the wall my administration has sent
to Congress a common-sense proposal to
end the crisis on the southern border it
includes humanitarian assistance more
law enforcement drug detection at our
ports closing loopholes that enable
child smuggling and plans for a new
physical barrier or wall to secure the
vast areas between our ports of entry in
the past most of the people in this room
voted for a wall but the proper wall
never got built I will get it built
this is a smart strategic see-through
steel barrier not just a simple concrete
wall it will be deployed in the areas
identified by the border agents as
having the greatest need and these
agents will tell you where walls go up
illegal crossings go way way down
San Diego used to have the most illegal
border crossings in our country in
response a strong security wall was put
in place this powerful barrier almost
completely ended illegal crossings the
border city of El Paso Texas used to
have extremely high rates of violent
crime one of the highest in the entire
country and considered one of our
nation's most dangerous cities now
immediately upon its building with a
powerful barrier in place
El Paso is one of the safest cities in
our country simply put walls work and
walls save lives so the kind of wall the
kind of barrier that he's calling for
now is so sensible and so modest that
Democrats look like absolute lunatics
being opposed to it and this shows again
how effective Trump can be when he has
helped crafting his message because
during the campaign when he was off the
coffee was talking about wall Mexico is
gonna pay for its me a big beautiful
wall there's gonna be one door in the
wall and so you had this image in your
mind of this huge 40-foot concrete
towering something looks like from Lord
of the Rings or something type structure
stretching across the entire border like
the Great Wall of China and that's the
way he was talking about on the campaign
off-the-cuff and it was very easy for
Democrats to oppose that because they
could say well that's crazy obviously
we're not gonna do that
be a total waste of money it would take
years to bill there would be billions
upon billions upon billions of dollars
he'd be building a wall across stretches
of border where nobody's even crossing
anyway so it's very easy for them to
oppose that but now that he's kind of
crafted the message more it's become
thing that you really can't oppose well
you can and you just look crazy doing it
because now he's talking about right
we're gonna put strategically built
strategically placed steel barriers
along the sections of the border that
the Border Patrol asks us to put yeah
Wilkin solve them they're the experts
they know what's going on on the border
they'll tell us where they need the
barriers and we'll put them there it's
as I said it's it's modest it's it's
it's completely sensible we already have
stuff like that there are already
sections of the border that have these
kinds of barriers and so all Trump is
really saying is let's finish it let's
put through those barriers and the other
places where it's needed according to
the people who who who are experts in
this in this kind of stuff why would you
oppose that there's no there is no
reason at all to oppose that it just
doesn't make any sense
well Democrats oppose it because they
simply cannot support common-sense
things anymore especially if Trump
proposes them more if any Republican
oppose proposes them they just can't
they can't support it speaking of which
at these State of the Union speeches the
fun part course is always to see what
people stand to clap for and then what
lines cause them to sit solemnly with
their hands folded in their laps and you
can learn a lot about a party or about a
politician based on that so here's just
one example here's a clip of Trump
talking about putting an end to child
sex trafficking now you would think when
it comes to applause lines that's the
safest applause line you could possibly
offer is we're gonna put an end to child
sex trafficking right I mean everyone
can applaud that unless you are
alexandria kzo Cortes here she is now
here's the line and I want you to watch
her her reaction to it today he leads
investigations into the scourge of
international sex trafficking
Alvin says that if I can make sure these
young girls get their justice I've
really done my job thanks to his work
and that of his incredible colleagues
more than 300 women and girls have been
rescued from the horror of this terrible
situation and more than 1500 sadistic
traffickers have been put behind bars
that's pretty remarkable she she big
grudgingly stands after a while and
doesn't clap she she's you could see her
practically rolling her eyes like
alright I'll stand and then she just
cysts her with her with her hands folded
refusing the clap and I remind you
everyone else is clapping at the idea of
fighting child sex trafficking AOC can't
even stand for that or clap for that but
if you really want to see the Democrats
looking sullen then let's check out the
reaction to Trump talking about ending
late term abortion as I said this was
the best part of speech this was the
most effective moment once again this is
something that I think Trump needs help
framing and and coming up with the words
for to address this sort of issue but
this is also a message that your jet
you're not going to hear it from other
Republicans especially at a State of the
Union and especially in terms this
direct and straightforward other
Republican presidents maybe have spoken
briefly about protecting the unborn or
protecting life and then they just
quickly move on but Trump goes into more
detail so now what I'm gonna do is I
want to play the whole the whole bit for
you but I'm gonna play first just the
beginning of him when he's describing
late term abortion and I want you to
focus on Chuck Schumer's expression and
then we'll play the rest so so here's
Trump describing the murder of fully
developed infants in the third trimester
who can feel pain and I want again I
want you to watch Chuck Schumer as he
describes it here it is lawmakers in New
York cheered with delight upon the
passage of legislation that would allow
a baby to be ripped from the mother's
womb moments from birth these are living
feeling beautiful babies who will never
get the chance to share their love and
their dreams with the world okay I mean
the guy
he's literally turned into a Batman
villain I mean he is acting he is like
the penguin now from from Batman he's
sitting there with this evil grin as
Trump talks about children being ripped
from their mothers wound that that's the
phrase a children ripped from their
mother's womb they never have a chance
at life and Chuck Schumer is sitting
there with this smile I mean he's
excited by the thought of it it's so
creepy Schumer he looks giddy about
abortion I would call him a ghoul but I
feel like that would be unfair to ghouls
and then here's the here so here's the
rest of Trump's remarks on abortion and
as as you watch this I want you to watch
especially the white pantsuit per day
brigade all of the Democrat women I want
you to watch how they react here it is
and then we had the case of the governor
of Virginia where he stated he would
execute a baby after birth to defend the
dignity of every person I am asking
Congress to pass legislation to prohibit
the late term abortion of children
let us work together to build a culture
that cherishes innocent life
now he's not calling for an end to all
abortion here he was just calling for an
end to late term abortion the killing of
babies who can feel bad pain and are in
many cases viable outside of the womb
but the Democrat women are totally
bummed by that you saw them they're
sitting there completely bummed out
about the idea of not killing babies
because they're so psyched about killing
babies that anytime someone talks about
not killing babies they they immediately
start pouting when they're on the verge
of tears almost as trump is just saying
hey let's not kill babies in the third
trimester you know they can feel pain
and they're and let's not do that and
all the all the liberal women are
sitting there like no that's my that's
my impression of Democrat women no
honestly if you if you were writing your
own comic book and you decided to invent
a political party as the villains of
this comic book world this is what you'd
create the modern Democrat Party is a
comic book villain they are cartoonishly
evil at this point that they would be
scowling at the idea of protecting you
you've got Trump saying we have to
protect all innocent life and these
women are scowling about it are you
kidding me but it wasn't all sullenness
on the part of the Democrats they did
erupt in raucous applause one time and
this was supposed to be an inspirational
moment of unity or whatever but I found
it pretty gross to be honest so watch
this all Americans can be proud that we
have more women in the workforce than
ever before
don't sit yet you know like this
and exactly one century after Congress
passed the constitutional amendment
giving women the right to vote we also
have more women serving in Congress than
at any time before
all right now they're excited they're
applauding because why because they're
applauding themselves they couldn't
applaud protecting babies they had
trouble applauding the end of sex
trafficking they obviously didn't
applaud protecting the border defending
our laws but they'll applaud themselves
yay we're women we got elected great
good for you yeah awesome
okay personally I don't care that you're
women I don't care that a bunch of women
got elected I wouldn't care if no women
were elected I wouldn't care if only
women were elected if there were zero
women in Congress or only women it makes
no difference to me
I don't care at all in the slightest it
doesn't matter the only thing that
matters to me is with with politicians
anyway it's what what laws what policies
do they support that's that's the only
thing I care about so excuse me if I'm
not welling up with tears of pride and
and joy because a bunch of infanticidal
self-obsessed identity politicking
egomaniacal women got elected which is
what most of them are this time around I
mean the the vast majority of these
women that were elected or Democrats and
they all fall into that category because
that's what the Democrat Party is now so
there is no oh yeah well their intent on
killing babies but at least they're
women okay so they have two
x-chromosomes
who cares I don't doesn't matter to me
it's not progress okay when you elect
infanticidal people to Congress it
doesn't matter what gender they are
that is not progress that is a step back
so yeah if I could replace all those
women with pro-life men I would do it in
a heartbeat
absolutely call me misogynist I don't
care by the way I don't want to belabor
the point too much but just by way of
comparison here is the white pantsuit
brigade applauding a ten year old
cancer survivor watch this when Grace
completed treatment last fall her
doctors and
nurse cheered they loved her they still
loved her with tears in their eyes as
she hung up a poster that read last day
of chemo
[Applause]
thank you very much grace you are a
great inspiration to everyone in this
room thank you very much okay so they
applauded kind of unenthusiastic polite
applause just sort of you know the
applause Fritz want you to compare the
applause for themselves was
exponentially more enthusiastic and
raucous and congratulatory
self-congratulatory in their case that's
what they're excited why I say
self-obsessed egomaniacs that's what
they're excited about it's about
themselves congratulating themselves so
all-in-all Trump came off very well and
the Democrats did themselves no favors
so big win for Trump one other thing I
wanted to mention Camilla Harris reacted
to Trump's pro-life message last night
with a tweet and the tweet was your
standard Democrat cliche she said
politicians should not tell women what
to do with their bodies okay only it was
one of those things where they you see
on Twitter where in between each word
there's a clapping hand emoji I mean
you've seen that right which what is
that anyway what who does that in real
life who in real life will clap in
between each word to emphasize their
points I've never seen it so how did
that become what would that even look
like politicians should not tell women I
mean what is that does anyone do that
putting that aside I find it interesting
that Democrats are still using this
talking point and you see how you see
how the Democrats liberals they just
they are not consistent and they make no
effort to be consistent and they hold
views that are so crazy and so
delusional that they they can't really
apply them consistently so in this case
if they were actually being consistent
well they can't use slogans like this
anymore politicians should not
tell women what to do with their bodies
well according to them men could get
pregnant
isn't this transphobia shouldn't Camilla
Harris this should be a big scandal on
the Left Camilla Harris is a transphobic
bigot because Trump was talking about
abortion and what does Camille Erickson
she immediately associates that with
women and she says don't tell women what
to do with their bodies well a man can
get pregnant can T so this is not you
can't defy what we are not defying we
make up our own gender so I would we're
not defined by our biology I'm not gonna
have my gender assigned to me at birth
so how dare you Camilla Harris how dare
you associate pregnancy and babies and
reproductive health with only women that
is transphobia so all this stuff no
uterus no opinion if you're not a woman
you can't have an opinion about it
women's rights women's health all of it
you have to get rid of all of that you
can't say that stuff anymore according
to your own ideology that is all gone
you can't do that because it doesn't
mean anything anymore remember
there is no women's health what does
that mean if by women's health you're
referring to
you know abortion anything that has to
do with then the phrase women's health
is exclusionary transphobic right so you
see they can't the they can't even put
all the pieces of their own agenda and
their own ideology together and they
don't even try because they know that
everything conflicts with everything
else it all contradicts each other
because it's all so crazy so when
they're arguing for this when they're
making this argument then that you know
they'll make one argument over here and
then they'll put that argument down on
the shelf and put it and just leave it
to the side then they'll go over here
make a different argument that
contradicts that argument but they keep
it all together they never put it
together into one cogent coherent system
of thought because they can't all right
let's check some of your email go to the
inbox Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com if you want to
chime in with a question comment concern
whatever it may be
insult it's fine to so this is from
Ashley she says hi Matt what interesting
thing I noticed about the Washington
Post commercial was that they showed
footage of d-day and the landing on the
moon neither of which had journalists
even present such a dumb commercial keep
up the good work that's a good point
the yeah the filming how was it I didn't
even notice that I I'd have to go back
and watch the commercial I'll take your
word for it they had the the moon
landing okay the moon landing was filmed
by the astronauts themselves so so
apparently the moon landing has become
an instance of journalistic courage as
well they had nothing to do with all
they did was just reported on the news
great point Ashley Derek says hi Matt
hey Matt I recall at an episode a few
weeks ago you mentioned you watch
competitive bass fishing just curious if
you are a bass fisherman as well if so
that's awesome I strongly encourage you
to get involved in the sport help spread
knowledge of the awesome sport that's
that's an american-made sport see on the
water I do I don't even know if I could
call myself a bass fisherman because I
feel like you have to get to a certain
level of expertise before you can really
describe yourself in that way much like
you know if you write a blog post once
every two months you can't really call
yourself a writer right you've got to
write a lot more - so I don't know if I
rise that level but I do I do try to get
out on the water and in and fish mostly
for bass I can't say that I'm especially
good at it but if you have any tips
Derek please let me know Curtis says
Matt have you heard about the Liam
Neeson issue I was wanting to get your
thoughts on the subject hi Curtis yeah I
have followed that a little bit Liam
Neeson admitted that many years ago
after his friend was raped and she told
him about it this is back in Ireland and
he follow-up interview said this was 40
year 40 years
and she was raped told him about it said
that it was a black man who did it and
then he admitted in this interview that
he then prowled the streets for about a
week looking to get into a violent
altercation with a black man so that he
could get his revenge and he wanted to
take revenge on any person who looked
like the rapist not even just on the
rapist himself so that he says no
violence occurred but that's what he was
hoping for for a week because he was so
angry about this horrible thing that
happened and he admits that it was
terrible he says it was awful he's
remorseful about it he volunteered this
whole story which was not smart
rather a dumb move to do but that he
volunteered it said it's an awful
horrible thing to express great remorse
for it so what's my take well I think
there is no take really to have there's
no opinion to have on it yes it's it's
awful of course to consider taking
revenge on any person who has the same
race as a guy who did a horrible thing
that of course is awful and terrible and
but Neeson knows that he said so himself
it was a very long time ago he's
repented of it obviously so what is
there to say by I know it's become this
big thing viral thing and people are I
just don't know what opinion you can
offer because we could say well that's
terrible it's a horrible thing you
shouldn't do that and Liam Neeson says
yeah I know that's why that's my point I
was offering this as a story of a thing
that I'm that I feel great regret and
remorse for so okay alright let's just
move on with our lives I don't know what
the I don't know what else to say this
is from patty she says hi Matt I am
familiar with the question of the
eternal fate of unbaptized babies having
been troubled by it for years but I must
add a few corrections to the way you
presented it at least in the case of
Catholic theology mid 20th century
catechisms explained it as one a
theological supposition that was not
doctrine he did not have to be believed
and two that babies who died without
being baptized would not go to hell but
to limbo a place of perfect natural
happiness one such as Eden was before
the fall and to which the souls of the
good went but
or Christ open the gates of heaven it
was not a punishment and there was no
torment involved still I always rejected
the idea that God would not want all his
children with him and that he would have
to withhold to be the beatific vision
from souls who were unbaptized through
no fault of their own a learned priest
told me that the view of unbaptized
babies going to limbo instead of heaven
is no longer upheld by Catholic
theologians right paddy well I don't
think that I don't think you're
correcting anything I didn't say
anything that contradicts that I don't
think I did anyway as far as limbo it
was as you say a theological theory
based in my opinion on nothing other
than the imagination of theologians they
constructed this whole realm called
limbo basically out of whole cloth it
was just there's no basis for it's just
something that they came up with so in
my opinion we are not only not required
to believe it but I think that we should
we should believe it because it's not
based on anything other than the
speculations of medieval theologians and
I just don't know why that should really
carry any weight in this case and the
other problem is it also seems so I know
that if you speculate something like
limbo you think well you get around the
whole Hell thing there because even
though you're just we've just made up
this thing called limbo in your mind
you've got a neuron around hell because
you're saying well maybe you know
they're not it's not active suffering
and torment but first of all if it's
eternal if it's eternal separation from
God not to mention from I mean this is
played just for I mean if it's eternal
separation from but God not to mention
all of your loved ones and everything I
don't know how that would not be eternal
torment how is that not suffering but in
any case the other problem with it is
that it you know it kind of it
strips power from God it suggests that
God is not powerful enough to figure out
a way to get these babies into heaven
that it sort of presents a problem to
him that you can't fix and so he has to
cash them out somewhere else and the
other issue is that it takes kind of a
it turns the atonement into some pretty
weak sauce doesn't it if it can't even
cover dead infants if dead infants are
not covered by the atonement then
haven't you just severely mitigated the
effect and the power of Christ's saving
sacrifice so anyway I agree with you
from Lenny
he says Matt I thought your reasoning as
to why babies don't go to hell was not
good you said that a just and merciful
God wouldn't send babies to hell how is
that your determination isn't it
possible that you just don't understand
justice and mercy I just don't see how
you could presume to make those kinds of
declarations I think it's very possible
that some young people even babies are
damned upon death I would never presume
to tell God he can't do that we were all
sinners after all none are righteous
none at all
well Lenny as I explained yesterday and
here you are talking about you're not
talking about some limbo that you've
made up this is you're talking about
babies going to hell to be tormented for
all eternity that's what you're talking
about
you said damned right well as I
explained yesterday if the word mercy
has any has has a definition that
includes damning infants to trillions of
years of torture then the word has no
discernible meaning at all it just it
doesn't mean anything to say mercy I
want you come up how about this I'll
give you a challenge Lenny come up with
a definition of mercy come up with a
discernible meaningful definition of the
word mercy that could possibly include
torturing infants for trillions of years
can you do that because if you can't
then that creates a logical problem so
it's not about putting God in a box or
anything like that this becomes more of
like can God make a square
charcoal and the answer is no because
it's illogical it is a logical
contradiction can God make a boulder so
big that he can't lift it no it's a
logical contradiction I would say that a
merciful God damning infants to an
eternity of suffering is a logical
contradiction you've just put two
opposite things together and you can't
do that when we call God just and
merciful and loving we must mean
something
okay these words have to carry some
meaning and if when we say God is
merciful if all we really mean to say is
God is what he is
then again the sentence doesn't mean
anything and we have no guarantee in
that case that God is not cruel and
unjust and evil if you're talking that
all we can say about God is well here's
what it is and whatever he is that's
what he is true but that's all we can
say about God then we have no guarantee
at all that he's not that he's not a
cruel monster right point being if we
all we could say about God is that he is
that he is what he is then we end up
with a sort of like deism right where
God is this totally mysterious force
that we cannot say anything about but if
you insist
as I'm sure you do and as I do and as
scripture does and as Christianity has
four million for thousands of years that
God is merciful as opposed to cruel then
we must have some definition of mercy
that excludes cruelty right if we
include cruelty such
the cruelty of torturing infants if we
include that in the definition then
again we're back to this place of deism
where we can't say anything about God
because none of the words mean anything
so I say that God doesn't damn babies to
hell because when I say that I believe
that God is merciful and loving I mean
it I actually mean IIIi intend for that
sentence to mean something and so that's
all now I understand that the well a
loving God wouldn't do that argument is
often used to fallacious effect
oftentimes you love atheists and others
who use that argument in in in
illegitimate ways so I understand that
but there are certain things that we can
say a loving God wouldn't do because for
the millionth time if there's nothing
that we can rule out then just calling
God loving means nothing and stop saying
it you don't mean anything when you say
it so there we go
another example you know that we could
say well God can't do God can't lie okay
I feel very confident saying that God as
a as an all perfect all good all loving
being cannot lie so am i putting God in
a box am I am I am i daring to tell god
what he can and can't do no I'm not
telling him what to do but I am making a
declaration about what he does and
doesn't do doesn't lie because that
would be in contradiction with it in all
loving and all perfect being and I would
argue that sending babies to trillions
of years of torment is also in a
contradiction it may you know either
it could conscience I say it contradicts
his mercy the only other option is that
it contradicts his his his omnipotence
is his his power because if we're saying
that there's something like there's
nothing he can do right he'd just be for
some reason he has to send them there he
can't figure out a way to bring them in
well then now you've just taken power
from him so by entertaining this idea
you either strip him of mercy or you
strip them of power and I think that
that is the presumptuous thing and also
the very damaging thing because when you
go around saying this you it's very
scandalizing and I think it turns many
people off of faith and God and it gives
them an impression of God as this
utterly monstrous figure and I don't
think that's a good thing to do all
right we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed